Oh, hi, I'm here to
audition for
"forgettable
girl number three."
Oh.
Amy...
why don't
you have a seat.
There are some people here
who love you a whole lot.
They called me because
they think
you have a problem.
We think you're
addicted
to buying rounds
of stuff for people.
Shut up,
you piece of ( bleep )!
( Amy )
A month ago,
I was a normal girl
who liked watching
Wendy Williams
and sitting
alone in public parks.
But addiction can come into
anyone's life at anytime.
This is a dramatic
reenactment of my story.
( woman )
It's so weird.
I'm, like, a different
size at every store.
( woman )
Yeah.
At Zara, I'm a beast.
At J. Crew,
I'm like a supermodel.
Yeah, I'm a nine
across the board.
Like so skinny everyone's
worried about me.
Like, it doesn't
matter where I go.
I was used to my friends
ignoring me
and getting my name
wrong most of the time.
( all chanting )
Tonia, Tonia, Tonia,
Tonia, Tonia, Tonia...
Put it on the card.
( man )
Thank you.
What can I get
for you ladies?
Uh... you know what?
Round of drinks
on me.
Wow!
All right!
Whoo!
( all chanting )
Amy, Amy, Amy, Amy, Amy...
That was the moment
my whole life changed.
( woman )
Guys...
we are so
"Sex and the City" right now.
I'm Carrie.
You're Samantha.
Ahh...
You're Charlotte,
and...
( woman )
Who's Miranda?
Obviously me.
Oh, what about
the bathroom attendant?
She looks like
a lawyer.
Nailed it.
Yeah!
Know what time it is?
It's "a round of drinks
on me o'clock," bitches.
( all )
Whoo!
( all chanting )
Amy, Amy, Amy...
My addiction had
taken hold of me.
It was like a drug.
And also,
I was doing drugs.
Uh, babe,
you're spending way too
much money at the bars.
It's crazy.
Promise me you'll
get it under control.
Absolutely.
But I couldn't
get it under control.
I also cheated on him,
like, a ton.
No matter where I went,
my addiction followed.
Hi, um, will Plan "B"
also get rid of my UTI?
Round of pills
on me!
( all cheering )
♪
Amy...
why don't you
have a seat.
There are
some people here
who love you
a whole lot.
And they called me because
they think
you have a problem.
( man )
Oh, my God.
( woman )
Amy.
( sobbing )
Oh, my God,
what do you want?
What are you buying?!
I'll buy you
whatever you want!
Round on me!
Uh...
Hey, hey!
It's over.
( sobbing )
It was over.
( coin clanking )
Well, it's been, uh...
it's been 90 days
since I came here,
um, to the center.
Hi, I'm doing
a thing.
And I feel amazing.
I feel like
myself again.
Hi.
All right, I'll see you
at the event.
Um, everybody's so cool here
and-- oh, I know I look
a little bit different.
Um...
I tried doing my hair
in a new way.
Uh...
I've just been--
just doing me work and just--
just really focusing
on my poetry
and channeling
all my energy into that.
( sighing )
Here it goes.
"Rounds and rounds
"and rounds we go.
"Where will this
stop?
"Now I know.
"Who are you?
"Who am I?
Who is that,
who is that?"
♪